Gary to keep talking about investing in
startups but I don't have twenty five
thousand dollars in fact I'm six
thousand in debt and I have ninety three
dollars in my bank account what do I do
and you know you're getting this
constantly thousands of people tens of
thousands of people emailing me and at
some point [__] I gotta do something and
I was like all right I'm gonna show them
what I did when I had 93 my garage
saleed and sold stuff on eBay you got me
into this man you saved my life thank
you bro makes me happy me and my wife
started doing this a couple of months
ago look at that number nah man what did
you start with you thought it was 100
bucks my man
husband and I lost our means of
employment over covid and it was you
that got me into flipping sneakers and
so that got us through the the hump
there so
foreign